I believe that Humanity's original wound
if we have one is that we saw ourselves
separate from nature
truth to the idea that we are quickly
approaching a significant Tipping Point
for both human and planetary Health
despite the Breakneck pace of innovation
and Technology striving to solve these
problems some of which are truly
existential I can't help but feel the
solutions we need continue to elude us
this is a sensibility I share with my
friend today's guest Zach Bush who is
one of the more fascinating medical
Minds currently working to improve our
understanding of whole body and whole
planet Health today Mark Zach's fifth
appearance on the show but for those who
have yet to be acquainted with this
unique and gentle soul Zach is a triple
board certified physician he's an
internationally recognized thought
leader and educator on the microbiome
the focus of his advocacy centers on
soil and Food Systems as well as the
need for a radical departure from
factory farming and the many deleterious
impacts of chemical intensive farming
practices and he couples all of this
with Solutions not just for farmers and
consumers but also for Mega Industries
so that we can all work together for a
healthy future for not just ourselves
but also for the animals and the planet
at large today's exchange traverses many
important topics including in a broad
sense the link between human biology and
planetary biology we discussed the
microbiome we talk about how the quality
of our soil affects our health
actionable ways to regenerate the planet
and many other fascinating topics super
grateful to Zach for his wisdom and for
sharing today and I'm proud to offer up
this conversation with him so without
further Ado please hit that subscribe
button if you haven't already and enjoy
before we dive in this episode is
brought to you by Roca now I get asked
fairly consistently about the glasses
that you see me wearing on the show well
the answer is Roca these are
specifically the Hamilton frames I love
them all the frames that Roca makes are
high performance super light amazing
Optics they've got tons of great Styles
they never ever slip off my face and
I'll be sharing a bit more about Roka
later but for now enough let's uh let's
do the thing
[Music]
so nice to share space with you once
again my friend
it's been a minute since we last did
this a lot has happened you know since
then
um even more of course since our our
first podcast I think this is your fifth
appearance on the show not not including
what we did at the Nantucket project
maybe third I'm not sure but it was
definitely about five years ago or six
years ago that we must have first talked
so certainly a lot since we first met at
the conscious capitalism conference many
years ago that's right it's an
uncomfortable situation evolving where
the audience gets to watch us age yes
and have lots of opinions about that
right
but in kind of thinking about
what has transpired since we last sat
down you know of course uh we've all you
know weathered the pandemic we're
experiencing what's going on in the war
with war in Ukraine yes Global soil
degradation continues we're in the midst
of this Mass species Extinction what is
it the seventh Extinction yes
um you know what else there we have
Refugee crises uh seismic climate events
with increasing regularity this loss of
trust in institutions a
growing Rift in our ability to conduct
civil discourse that I think is when did
to
the social media algorithms that are
driving separation through the
siloization of increasingly bespoke
informational feeds we've got
exacerbation of racial strife and class
economics deepening the rift between the
Haves and the half-nots which of course
is fueling both dissent and anger and
conflict and culminating and violence
which is separating us from others from
ourselves from the planet
uh you know that that we all share and
and finally
um although of course the list is much
longer
we're experiencing the uh in real time
the maturation of artificial
intelligence which is currently
proliferating with blinding Speed most
recently by Dent of these new generative
tools like Chachi BT which if Innovation
continues as it most surely will will in
time although the timeline is much
debated inevitably give birth to AGI
artificial general intelligence which is
essentially a new life form so
I guess what I'm getting at to kind of
kick things off is that this moment does
feel historic in the sense that you know
we're emerging from this pandemic to
kind of now immediately grapple with
this emergent form of of rapidly
evolving technology which you know look
does have amazing use cases you know
don't get me wrong but it does feel like
it's placing Humanity Upon A precipice
and you know I don't in any way want to
be hyperbolic but there is this almost
inescapable sense that that we are
approaching a significant Tipping Point
for human and planetary health and I
know these are things that you've spent
a lot of time pondering so perhaps we
can open uh with uh grappling with what
is going on and and how you're
attempting to make sense of it yeah as a
dismal list to take through right it's
yeah I mean I kind of highlighted the
negative things uh at the cost of all
the positive things that are going on
and I'm I recognize that but well I
think it's relevant and it's actually an
echo of our very first combination
conversation six years ago when we were
taking a look at that list of
catastrophic chronic disease epidemics
that we were facing from autoimmune
disease to cancer to autism to
Alzheimer's so we made that catastrophic
list there kind of at the human level
and now you've laid out the kind of
macro version of that same discussion of
you there's only so far you can push by
by all logic systems in the end and
biologic systems play out in a lot of
different you know micro to macro
versions and so I've had a very blessed
life but a lot less blessed you know 12
15 years being steeped in the laboratory
looking at a single cell under the
influence of these you know toxic
environments that you've laid out and
then participating in very broad
spectrum visioning of where's Humanity
as a whole and where we're going and the
fun thing that we find is there's true
fractals in that in that if you find
something true at the Single Cell level
it's going to be true at the macro level
if I was going to just pick one really
concrete example of that I would say
it's the phenomenon of an isolated cell
and so when you
expose a cell that is part of a large
system so you could pick an intestinal
cell or something like that and you
isolate it from its billions of
neighbors that are all intestinal
epithelial lining cells use the barrier
between you and the outside world in
regard to the god
if you isolate that cell through toxin
exposure it immediately begins to
journey into cancer
and so in the end a cancer cell is an
isolated cell that's remained that way
long enough to start to accumulate
injuries because a single cell can't
actually be fully responsible for its
own energy source and all that it has to
be connected to the greater organism for
that energetics of repair and
regeneration to happen
at the macro level you find a child who
starts to get isolated socially
emotionally from their classroom and
kindergarten second grade and then
they're easy to radicalize by the time
they're 12 years old and they become a
malignant social agent and they step
into a classroom with school shootings
and the rest and so we become malignant
I.E damaging to our environment through
isolation
and if we go from that single cell to
that individual human now to the
societal level or we could say the
species level we see the same phenomenon
I believe that Humanity's original wound
if we have one is that we saw ourselves
separate from nature
and it's in that isolated Behavior
isolated belief system of we are
separate we somehow got rejected from
nature we have age-old religious myths
about kicked out of the garden and all
these things this this deep belief that
somehow we were rejected by Nature has
led to this exploitive extractive
destructive Behavior simply because
we're isolated in the same form that a
cancer cell becomes cancerous and
malignant to its organism we have become
cancerous to our organism which is a
single living system called planet Earth
that's a that's a you know fascinating
kind of dissection of
how the you know our focus on the micro
impairs our ability to perceive the
implications on the macro right and when
we think about
uh Western
progress and the scientific method
certainly we've been able to uh you know
develop therapies and
glean a greater understanding of our
world through a method that is focused
on uh extracting variables and and
looking at things in isolation like
that's the way you kind of better
understand things and I know you as a
doctor were on a track of literally just
studying one protein
you know and its impact on on on cancer
and that's certainly a lens through
which we can kind of better understand
systems on the micro level the problem
enters when we lose sight of of how that
interacts with the macro right and
um
and and and that I think requires a
certain humility about the
um the reach of the scientific method to
objectively understand everything and uh
deprecates an appreciation for
understanding the holistic nature the
incredibly infinitely complex way in
which you know our DNA our cells are you
know particle matter is always in
interplay with everything that surrounds
us and it's almost like you have to
uh you know look at it through almost a
psychedelic perspective to understand
that understand like the non-duality
Oneness of our existence in context with
the environment that supports us and and
so perhaps talk a little bit about like
you've sort of you know you were well
Along on this journey when we first
talked and that's seemed to mature over
the years but I feel like you have
entered a new phase in in your
perspective and you're thinking about
this interplay in particular
yeah I think
the human mind is limited in its
capacity to Grapple with quantum physics
or any infinite system because we have
such a finite perspective on the
universe it seems like you're quite far
away from me you know six feet away
there and it's impossible for my mind to
wrap my head around just how close we
are compared to the distance to the moon
or something simple like that you know
it's just like with the the
misperception of Being Human in that we
have these five senses that make it
appear give us the impression that we're
separate from the things around us has
both been our greatest gift I think and
maybe we come back to that in some ways
or and maybe is indicative of our
purpose really is why are we here like
why why have monkeys that can control
fire and then create technology and do
all that thing
it I think it and maybe it does have to
do with the ability that we achieve
through this separation that the five
senses offer
but the unfortunate side effects that
stepped in perhaps before we could even
find our identity and purpose was this
belief of separateness and the belief
that the finite
this has been something that we have
been witnessing in my laboratory in
deeper and deeper ways over the last 12
years and
I think that one way that we could back
into this is first acknowledging that uh
the way in which we study any cell is in
isolation and so I told you that a cell
isolate becomes cancer but we we
understand small intestine cells only in
the context of neighbors of small
intestine cells we don't understand what
they do when there's an immune system
that lies you know a micron behind that
you know tiniest fraction of a
millimeter behind that eighty percent of
your immune system exists with
quadrillions of cells interacting we've
never been able to study that because in
a Petri dish you need that isolated
single cell type to to do that and so we
have come to understand cardiovascular
disease cancer any form of you know
chronic dysfunction or disorder in the
body only in the context of isolation
and this seemed like a really relevant
way to study it because in that
reductionist approach we could give it
one stimulus and then understand what
the reactions to that one stimulus are
where we really
were short-sighted or perhaps just
unable to achieve in this current
version of science that we work within
is that what happens if there's 10
million inputs at once
you know there was no system smart
enough or question you know vague enough
to answer that and the only way to do
that is really in a clinical setting and
in the same way that we do reductionists
basic science laboratory in a Petri dish
we do reductionist science in our
clinical trials where we try to find the
most monotonous group of people possible
so that we can have the same predicted
outcome and so 45 to 65 year old white
males was the typical you know science
experiment in clinical research and then
you give them one drug and you control
for their diet control for everything
else make sure nothing else changes
the challenge that we quickly realized
over you know the Decades of this
approach to clinical research is that
it's very hard then to apply that data
set from that 55 to 65 year old white
man to a population of you know very
genetics and backgrounds ages males
females was a big piece of this problem
we now know that female biology does not
respond to pharmaceutical intervention
ever in the same way that a male
physiology really does so it doesn't
matter if it's a blood pressure medicine
or cholesterol medicine the female the
female is going to respond differently
just by that simple difference of a few
stimulus of estrogen and testosterone is
enough to screw up your whole
expectations of a drug
so then you add on to that age-related
changes and you know the deeper
questions of ethnic changes and all of
that we realize we don't really know
anything in the end after 100 Years of
peer-reviewed Science and Western
medicine at its best
it's pretty clear that we don't have any
real strong handle on what would be good
for a human entering a chemical
environment the answer is we don't know
although we know is it hasn't gone well
so far
our life expectancy is going down over
the last few decades not up despite stem
cell Innovations and everything you've
ever heard of that sounds super exciting
and positive genetics you know we didn't
didn't have the human genome decoded
when I started medical school we were we
we thought that we had 280 000 genes at
the time to find out that we only have
20 000 genes was part way through my
career you know we're we're way simpler
than we thought on on the nature level
and we're way more complex in our
reaction to our environment
and so this is birthed Industries like
epigenetics and things like that to
understand the influence of our
environment on something that we thought
was as stable as our genes now we find
out a single Gene can have 200 400
different endpoints can produce 200 or
400 different proteins depending on its
environment
you extrapolate that out towards 20 000
genes you find out wow Rich you could
make four million different bodies from
the genes your mother and father gave
you
and the body you have today is not the
result of mom and dad but the the
effects of the environment within the
womb and and more mysterious than that
then the effects of the environment on
your parents at the time that you were
conceived and so their emotional status
their physical and chemical environments
all of these things were playing in to
that moment of conception and
determining how those 20 000 genes would
behave and what body they would create
in the womb and then the moment you took
your first breath you began your journey
into self self-realization at the
genetic level and that changes minute by
minute every day and so it's on one hand
a grim reality wow we really miss the
boat on our reductionist definition of
what human life is and how it occurs and
its full potential when we were
reductionist in approach for the
excitement that I have now that we're
kind of steeping our patients into the
opposite direction which is Let's Go
full on holistic let's get you so
connected to Nature let's see if we can
get a billion inputs into you in a day
instead of you know five different meals
that you cycle in and out and just the
monotony of the typical diet or the
typical daily activities what if we give
you billions of different inputs at the
biologic level how resilient how
regenerative do you become and I think
that's our next journey is out of the
reductionist world and into this
holistic interconnected universe that we
call Earth
but to break from that reductionist
history and lends into science as a
means of gleaning truth to then say
we're going to expand the aperture and
just you know expose an individual under
under evaluation to a billion inputs or
whatever it is how do you then extract
any kind of meaningful truth out of that
that is instructional in terms of how
you you know guide people towards Better
Health it's a really important question
and it's one in which we realize not
only do we have to to surrender the old
Paradigm of reduction of science we also
have to
surrender the old belief system about a
patriarchal you know disbursement of
prescriptive medicine and we have to let
it be the opposite in which the the
concept of health is going to have to
rebirth from inside every single person
the only laboratory that is relevant to
you is your body
and there's you know somewhere around 50
or 70 trillion human cells in there that
are working with 1.4 quadrillion
bacteria an unknown number of fungi and
then you've got 14 quadrillion
mitochondria which are tiny little
bacteria living inside your 70 trillion
cells and all of those cells are
swapping genetics in real time all the
time every millionth of a second new
genetic potential and so that complex
system actually gets to be interpreted
every day by your senses do you have
pain in your hip in your knee in your
ankle today if we change your
environment is that change tomorrow
that's the only relevant scientific
experiment for every human on the planet
going forward
and it should have been previously as
well because we have been really flawed
in our approach to applying population
statistics to individuals historically
and to this very day there's you know a
million doctors offices today that are
telling somebody this clinical trial
with 100 000 people in it showed this
result of a four percent reduction in
your
cholesterol if we put you on this
medication so if I put you on this
medication we expect a four percent
reduction in your cholesterol
if anybody's taking a statistics 101
class the first full day is that you can
never take a population statistic and
apply it to an individual
if you tell somebody look we we reduce
death in this clinical trial therefore
by 20 therefore we're going to reduce
your likelihood of death if we put you
on this drug it is that is the fallacy
number one of statistics and we're
taught that and then we immediately
forget that because we don't know what
to tell people then well if we can't
tell them that then why did we do this
study
the only way in which population
statistics is even helpful is at like
the decision-making tree of you know
triaging or coming up with some sort of
tactical or strategic decision at the
public health level if I was you know
dictating Medicare or something like
that then public health statistics would
be interesting okay if we make this
intervention to two million people we
would expect this population effect and
so you can't say there's been a 20
reduction in individual cells so
population studies that we call clinical
trials are not applicable to the
individual it's a weird phenomenon and
so instead we're going to have to come
up with a new set of metrics where
clinical research begins to be done at
the individual level which might be
impossible to imagine 20 years ago but
we've had this explosion of what we call
biohacking and so we have all these new
devices that people can wear on their
own bodies and get their own data you
know day in and day out of how much REM
sleep did they get how much you know
inflammatory markers they have in their
urine how much you know blood sugars in
their in their bloodstream when they
first wake up in the morning like this
data is now interestingly readily
available to an individual consumer with
absolutely no medical training
I think that similar to the probiotics
which were kind of our first foyer into
saying hey some bacteria might be good
because up until the 1970s we just
thought all bacteria were our enemy
there was a crack in that we fast
forward 40 50 years we find out oh you
know what probiotics was actually not an
answer to gut health you can't actually
create a diverse ecosystem by taking
billions of copies of three species of
bacteria as you do in a probiotic
but at least it got us down that road
and I feel the same way for biohacking
is that we've been super reductionist
again and people are running around
spending hours a day
keeping track of their blood sugar and
their hours of sleep and all of this and
for that I see a lot of them really
missing out on life
relationships aren't alive their their
Connection in nature is not alive their
connections are just feeling freaking
glad to be alive has been a forgotten
goal and instead it's my successes my
blood sugar and my resting heart rate
and my heart rate variability and my
might worry ring data and that's an
unfortunate result of what seemed to be
a good idea of like let's strive for for
Health and Longevity
when perhaps we hadn't yet answered the
question of what does it feel like to be
alive maybe that's the goal
brought to you today by Roca classes are
not something you normally think about
as a piece of performance gear which
when you think about it is kind of
insane because you can't perform at your
best if you can't see well the Geniuses
at Roka basically rebuild eyewear from
the ground up no matter how active you
are or how much you sweat these things
never slip or fall off your face they're
super durable they look awesome and
they've got tons of super classy modern
styles to choose from I've been rocking
rokas for about four years at this point
I love them I'm a big fan of the
Hamilton style and gloss black that's
this Frame right here as well as clear
or I guess they call them vintage on the
website and if you want to try them out
for yourself you can do that right now
and unlock 20 off your order with the
code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
yeah I heard you once say
every biohacking event I've ever been to
is accelerating the death of everybody
there which is a hyperbolic statement uh
but yeah uh an interesting one you know
nonetheless in that uh you know I gather
from what you just shared that this idea
that again it's reductionist like look
at these markers and make decisions
accordingly
um but the average consumer is doing
that with a limited amount of Education
to properly interpret not just the
meaning of those data points but the
context in which they live right so I
don't neces I mean listen I'm wearing
these things you know I I look at the
data I hold it Loosely I find it
interesting but I try not to let it
dictate like my decisions
um
so I don't know that it's a black or
white thing I think uh greater
information in the hands of consumers is
probably a good thing overall but I
think it needs to be paired with
adequate information and education so
that they can understand the importance
or lack of importance of of what all of
this means I suppose and just kind of
pulling another thread and what you
shared
um not to play Devil's Advocate but to
you know imagine
the perspective of the general
practitioner or the cardiologist who is
listening to this or or watching it
watching watching this right now and and
bristling at what you just shared and
thinking I know that if I subscribe a
Statin to this patient who has high
cholesterol I'm lowering the risk of
having a significant or potentially
fatal uh heart incident as a result and
so you can't tell me that what I'm doing
is not having some kind of benefit
so how do you you know kind of
communicate with the practitioner who is
rooted in our traditional system right
now in terms of uh you know how we're
talking about you know some of the
low-hanging fruit of chronic diseases
that that are unnecessarily killing or
debilitating millions of people every
year but are also somewhat uh
ameliorated through simple interventions
yeah so I I feel for any practitioner or
scientist listening to this because we
feel trapped right and so it's like deep
down we're pretty sure that nature
wasn't waiting to to perfect human
longevity for us to discover statin
drugs
that's kind it would be a pretty
narcissistic belief that we were going
to somehow do cholesterol better than
the complex endocrine system with the
liver of a human being
and so really the learning of a
physician is around
losing belief and trust that humans can
change
and so we know fundamentally that
cholesterol is a direct relationship to
the environment
food being an obvious one but many
anything that causes vascular
inflammation is going to call for more
LDL production from your liver to reduce
that inflammation and so really
fundamental to a pharmaceutical model of
Education you have to lose hope that
humans will fundamentally change their
behavior and we do that pretty quickly
we we're trained to lose hope or perhaps
humans show us good reason to lose hope
in them quickly because as doctors were
said yeah you should tell them to change
their diet too and so which is well you
should eat less fatty foods or we make
up these things or don't eat as much
Coca-Cola and you know all these things
that we say
and the results don't change in their
cholesterol after a few months and we're
like see I I told you to change your
diet but that didn't work so I'm going
to give you a drug that I know isn't
like Nature's answer to this but it's my
best effort it's the thing I've been
given in my toolbox to to lower your
cholesterol so that's a bit of the
rationale that has to happen inside any
physician being given a toolbox of
chemicals that certainly aren't from
nature and
another way of looking at is there any
cancer in history that was ever caused
by a lack of chemotherapy
as you really wrap your head around that
and you start to realize like no like
that's not the cause of a disease is a
lack of a poison on the end of the
disease right and so same way as is
blood pressure occurring in the
individual due to a lack of blood
pressure medications
and so in this simple way we can start
to realize like okay no we've actually
just been trained in a modality of
allopathic Western medicine that simply
doesn't offer us the opportunity to ask
root cause problems and questions or
come up with root Solutions
so that's been my journey as you know
developing chemotherapy 2006 2007 to now
even having closed my clinic to to get
my patients out of that mentality of
their coming to me for health and
instead go to this model that we have
called journey of intrinsic Health where
my interaction with every single client
now is that you are the Healer and I and
we're going to surround You by resources
and an environment of thought really
it's a philosophy School of eight weeks
that's going to reintroduce you to your
sense of self-identity to begin with if
you don't start at that sense of
self-identity then I'm going to risk
giving you a bunch of data or a bunch of
exercises that you're going to think are
the purpose of your life to beat the
cancer or to reduce your blood pressure
or to have less depression in your life
you didn't come into a body as complex
as a human to overcome the diseases of
being disconnected from nature I I
fundamentally believe we are more fun
more unique to the to the interplay
between Cosmic dust and this thing that
we call a life we have so much
connectedness in our capacity to have
conscious
thought abstract systems of belief
abstract systems of visioning and and
you know the possibilities of the future
if we forget that and we start to again
be reductionist in our definition of of
success of the cancer shrunk two
centimeters the last six months that's
good right I don't know is it good are
you enjoying your life are you do you
know why you're here are you so
interconnected with your family that you
just can't wait to come off the pillow
in the morning
or are you isolated and depressed and
don't know why you're here and your
tumor is shrinking or growing maybe
that's not the point so that's kind of
where we got in our Clinic is like wow
we got to get people way backed up
before we even address any of the
dis-ease or disorder going on in that
body we got to reconnect to The
Originals question of who are you what
gives you Joy what lights you up what
makes you want to stay because to make
you stay in an unhappy place where you
feel disconnected and you are part of
the cancer of Humanity on the planet
we're not helping the system in the end
sure and you're not you're not exactly
Paving a you know a solid path towards
healing without exactly having that
conversation and and deconstructing that
and finding a a path forward of meaning
and purpose and fulfillment and ikigai
and all the rest right like
that is the difference between the you
know the very reductionist like let's
look at these cells and what's going on
and how do we treat them versus the
organism and the super organism that
that you know is is really a play right
here right and and that's a you know
it's a it's contrarian to our allopathic
system and I think is a pill for a lot
of people that that's difficult for a
lot of people to swallow and absorb and
and kind of
um contemplate uh so where do you think
we are right now in terms of progress
towards a more expanded uh macro
perspective on healing healing and
health I mean particularly since we last
spoke yeah it's I think we're speeding
towards it as a society because the
reductionist approach is failing so
quickly now you know and so what seemed
ridiculous you know to my colleagues and
to me 12 years ago around the philosophy
that cancer can actually be predicted by
its the relationship of to the gut
microbiome that was heresy when in 2008
2009 when those studies started to come
out like it didn't play into our model
of how cancer occurs at all didn't make
any sense fast forward now we've now
found every disease Maps right back to a
shift or a loss of diversity at the
microbiome level I.E a disconnect from
the diversity of nature itself so
fortunately science itself has quickly
catching up here to say oh my gosh not
only is it not reductionists it's not
even about human cells talking the human
cells have to be talking to the
ecosystem at large every single
bacterium fungi in the environment has
the opportunity to give stimulus towards
Health to the individual human that's
holding that ecosystem within itself
and in our lab we get to see this quite
literally and quickly and this is where
my biotech company got its foothold is
understanding how do cells communicate
in relationship to the microbiome
human cell systems I was an
endocrinologist which is kind of the
system of hormones that help various
organ systems communicate and stay in
Cooperative effort towards a single
healthy human body
but the hormones were understood to be
very specific to human cells by and
large and we knew that the human
hormones thyroid Etc weren't speaking
directly to the to the gut microbiome
for example
and so there was a lack of understanding
of what would be the system that would
be trans species and we stumbled into
this by accident as a lab group in 2012
when we were studying soil and so soil
it turns out has an enormous amount of
the metabolites or breakdown products
from bacteria and fungi that are the
result of them digesting macronutrients
so you can imagine like you know a tree
falls in the forest and all the
microbiome fungi everything move in and
to digest that down into soil
while it goes from Oak tree down to
digested composted soil there's a lot of
eating going on and in all of that
eating the bacteria are making these
side products that we call metabolites
that turn out to be the communication
network of the ecosystem and that was
our Discovery in 2012 was seeing these
molecules
I saw a three-dimensional model of this
thing and it turned out it looked like a
lot like the chemotherapy I used to make
out of vitamin A compounds which was a
nutrient from plants and so it was that
moment where I got to ask that exciting
question of like wow we have been for
you know maybe 40 000 years of
indigenous you know plant medicine going
after plants for the medicinal quality
turmeric curcumin these things go back
thousands and thousands a year Chinese
medicine and Chinese herbal medicine
seven thousand years back at least
and so we we've long recognized that the
plants had it
to my knowledge you know at least at
this time I I don't know that we ever
went after the soil for medicine I.E the
bacteria and the fungi for medicine and
that was the shift that we made in 2012
was wondering could that be medicine to
humans and we found out that was much
more important than medicine it was
actually the communication Network
between the human cells and this family
of molecules broadly speaking is called
redox molecules and that's reduction in
oxidation which is a description of the
movement of electrons and so what's
happening in soil systems which is what
your gut ultimately is this is a complex
soil system that you carry around inside
of you
it creates a liquid circuit board for
the transit of information and these
tiny little carbon molecules all line up
in this colloidal structure within a
water state to move information just
like the the chip in your cell phone or
your computer does your central
processing unit is moving information so
that liquid circuit board
is allows cells to talk over great
distances very rapidly and so that was
our breakthrough and so this was the
first time maybe ever that humans got to
start to observe human cells in Petri
dishes
in the context of Nature's communication
flow and what we saw immediately happen
was resilience and regeneration
and so if you put intestinal cells in a
Petri dish and you expose them to the
most common toxin that soil carries
which is glyphosate which is the main
molecule in Roundup which is the most
common herbicide on the planet currently
we use about 300 million pounds a year
in the United States globally four
billion pounds of this stuff goes into
our Soil and Water Systems and is
exposed to our gut lining all over the
place through the food we eat through
this water we drink actually through the
rainfall now 85 percent of the rain in
the United States 85 percent of the air
we breathe so this chemical breaks the
tight junctions and GAP Junctions
creating isolation between the the
intestinal lining creating a leak and
this has now been popularized with the
term leaky gut and the medical
literature it's referred to as gut
permeability
but that leaky gut phenomenon is the
result of that injury of isolation
happening to billions of cells at once
due to exposure and so this was you know
something that obviously pharmaceutical
companies were fascinated with finding a
target for because if somebody could
crack that code my God what a
blockbuster drug to find out that nature
had cracked the code long long before
probably should have amazed us too much
but it it Still Remains amazing as we
see this happen in Petri dishes every
day in our lab is that as soon as that
communication Network goes up all of
those cells damaged or otherwise start
making more and more tight junctions to
the point where they're 30 or 40 percent
more in integrally Connected than before
the injury
and so this has been a really
fascinating look at the grace of the
nature that we are from that we come out
of which is it repairs faster and more
vigorously than it injures as long as it
has unfettered access to information
nature finds a way right and and and
then what you just shared I can't help
but think of the example
um that is commonly kind of discussed
which is the ways in which uh you know
the the Trees of a forest communicate
with each other through their root
networks and through the fungal networks
that connect them through you know the
soil uh to you know create this
communication Network that
um is always operating to protect the
hole over the individual right like it's
kind of mind-blowing how that all works
and we're only beginning to kind of
really understand that and to see that
pattern show up in other aspects of
biology and human biology so it's that
my micro macro thing like we see it
within ourselves we see it play out in
nature and then in even thinking a
little bit more broadly about that
I went to uh a screening of of this
movie pie the other day have you ever
seen this movie oh it's okay so it's
Darren aronofsky's first film and it's
the story of a young brilliant
mathematician math theorist who who
becomes obsessed with trying to
understand uh the laws of the universe
through mathematics and he's seeing
patterns everywhere and of course you
know the Fibonacci sequence which recurs
throughout nature and all these
different ways all the way from you know
the shells that you find on the beach to
you know the spiral pattern of of the
Universe and everything in between right
and he's determined or convinced that
all of this can be reduced to a
mathematical number that will explain
everything to the point uh of Madness
because it's driving him crazy but the
point being that there are patterns that
recur through nature on the micro all
the way up to the macro and to your
point like this is is you know kind of
your area of focus like how do these
things that we kind of understand in the
micro play out in the macro and how can
we better understand
ourselves and our place
uh within this ecosystem
uh in terms of how that interplay works
so that we can live simpatico with it
like in in unity with it like in
Integrity with it as opposed to in
opposition to it or in a way in which
we're we're you know an antagonist to
the environment that supports us and
that antagonistic relationship is really
the Catalyst or the driver of all of
these maladaptions that that we see in
terms of
um you know whether it's disease or or
our inability to live synchronously with
the planet with our you know kind of
fellow biological creatures is driving
all of these
um negative outcomes through disease
through conflict through
um uh the degradation of the environment
and you know on and on and on
yeah yeah it's super accurate and that
that fractal or Fibonacci kind of
phenomenon where you see it at all
levels of nature it gets pretty exciting
because you mentioned the mycelial
network connecting all the trees and
mentioned that you know all those trees
are trying to protect the hole all the
time
and that's gotten really trippy for me
to consider in recent years because that
was our initial thought process too when
we saw human cells repairing faster and
reconnecting at rates we didn't know
possible because we'd never seen healing
happen in a Petri dish it's actually not
possible because it's an isolated system
the second law of Thermodynamics says
any system left in isolation will
increase its chaos
so why do the why do the cardiologists
or the doctors listening to this
including myself back in the day believe
that the drug was necessary because we
had never believed healing to be
possible in a damaged cardiovascular
cell or whatnot we had never seen it
really truly go back to some previous
state of being
uh it's damage control at Best in a
Petri dish and so we didn't believe in
healing I didn't believe in healing
until I saw cells reconnected through
this communication network of the
microbiome to do things that we didn't
think possible
sorry to interrupt but like was there a
certain inflection point in that where
you cut you had sort of a Dawning
Epiphany about about this that that
transitioned you out of that traditional
method you know or approach into kind of
your current thinking it was slow you
know because uh you know first of all my
thinking it started changing even when I
was in Academia so I was starting to
watch vitamin A compounds kill cancer
really effectively got a clinical trial
started off in my basic science around
that and so I was already starting to
realize wait maybe we shouldn't be
poisoning bodies maybe we should be
feeding bodies maybe nutrition is going
to be more effective ultimately than
than trying to poison people with with
cancer so I was already starting to kind
of go through that you know very
uncomfortable realization I've been
going the wrong direction for 17 years
in Academia
yeah and so that had begun and then
exiting to start a nutrition center in
rural Virginia in one of the most
impoverished you know parts of the
country with the goal of if we can
figure out how to get the low
socioeconomic you know sectors of our
communities to figure out how to be
self-empowered in their eating to to get
out of the chronic disease happening
then it would work everywhere in the
world going to Santa Monica or something
to teach wealthy people how to eat vegan
seemed like a bit of a chasing after the
wind as far as like our true Public
Health crisis as foot so laughs
not to diminish the importance of Santa
Monica health I guess but but we go out
into that space and quickly in that
space started to you know make some of
these breakthrough discoveries that
nutrition was really fast acting
compared to drugs like to you start a a
diabetes drug you don't expect them to
you know go through any dramatic healing
events you expect their blood sugar to
slowly go down all this we were putting
people on these plant-based meta you
know diets and everything else and
finding that they were would reverse
type 2 diabetes in four weeks like
numbers that I just couldn't believe
obesity resolving itself very quickly as
we reconnected people to their Gardens
and start growing their own food and
seeing the impact not just of the
nutrition but being in the sunshine
breathing real air so they were having a
holistic reconnect to Nature through
food
and so that radical experience was
happening but even when I you know first
discover those molecules as a potential
Source in soil as in future medicine I
was still stuck in my Western medicine
Paradigm so the first cells I studied
that on were mcf7 breast cancer cells
and did all my old chemotherapy stuff
you know kind of mentality to them and
when it saw it doing crazy unexpected
things I was like well I'm gonna just
start doing that intravenously so I was
making my own stuff and intravenously
injecting into myself at liters a day
thinking the more the better like I got
a overwhelmed my system with healing you
know all this stuff
you fast forward a few years it didn't
really start to work until we started
using much much lower almost homeopathic
usage of this stuff in the gut rather
than in the vein you can't bypass
biology and expect biologic result and
and so it was this very slow Evolution
out of out of the reductionist and kind
of paternalistic I gotta do something to
the cells to to realize we are a living
system that is self-correcting
self-repairing
and that's what you described in the
forest those those trees are nurse
mating the whole Forest into a higher
state of being
which doesn't necessarily mean no death
it doesn't mean don't don't let anything
change and that's been kind of my slow
maturation I think in the last few years
is realizing that to preserve you know
some previous version of human health
isn't Nature's goal nature is constantly
moving forward on this planet for four
billion years to the next better
iteration of life
and it seems if we just look at the
genomics of the planet the definition of
Nature's version of what is better it is
more diversity
at every single moment this nature is
pressing discovering Reinventing
creating new life on this planet we've
gone from a few species of slime molds
to thousands of species of butterflies
over the last four billion years you
know it's just like there's such a
pressure in nature to create the next
thing more Beauty more diversity more
intelligence and it's been climbing that
way for the four billion years and so we
start to say well what really is the
goal of humanity at this crisis point
that you so well began us at why are we
here right now depending on why are we
the driving force of this sixth
Extinction how did we become the
existential crisis is one question but
to what end is maybe a more important
question what is the end of this
extinction look like it's interesting
because I I have considered you
an optimist to the point of Pollyanna at
times but that's a pretty gloomy
pessimistic perspective well it's it's
already happening you know you described
it really well at the beginning you know
the the amount of
just ecosystem refugees climate refugees
we have in Africa right now Mali the
country of Mali is just being
desertified at such an alarming rate
over the last three years uh and you
know the global governments decide they
were going to build a green wall to keep
the desert from coming any further so
they they try to raise 60 billion
dollars and plant 8 000 kilometers of
trees along the southern and and of the
desert there just to stop the
encroachment because people were
starving to death
the the speed at which the collapse of
Food Systems is happening there is just
just never been seen before uh just in
the Horn of Africa that little tiny
corner of the of the continent right now
we have an estimated 20 million people
starving
just in that little corner when Lynn
twist who's one of my great friends and
most revered you know Public Health
people out there she started Pacha mom
Alliance and before that with Warner
Earhart and the rest was running the
hunger project globally and then towards
the you know late 20th century and when
they were doing their work they were
trying to get the global hunger numbers
down from 14 million down to 4 million
was their goal they wanted to hit 4
million you know decrease by 10 million
those starving over the course of the
1990s
here we are in 2023 just one generation
later and we have 20 million people
starving in just one little corner of
Africa let alone the rest of the globe
and so we are we are seeing the collapse
of human biology on that grand scale of
starvation but we can also see it just
in sperm counts we've seen a 57 percent
decrease in sperm counts in the United
States over my lifetime
that's resulted in one in three males
now infertile by sperm counts not just
in the U.S but in Western countries
altogether
we are now heading for you know the end
of fertility and the end of food systems
and and and and as you've laid it out
there so we are losing relationship with
our environment in real time
and so the concept of we need to go buy
or hack ourselves back to 33 years old
so that we're healthy is missing the
point that the biology is eroding right
beneath our feet now I am a Pollyanna
and I am damn optimistic and I don't
think that is our future
but to make that something other than
our future
we're going to have to do something
radical which is what I would argue the
force does every day is Imagine
something bigger and better than it is
today
and so we don't need to go back to 1940s
Food Systems to get healthy we need to
imagine the humanity that comes after
this version of humanity and we need to
start growing that for us and so we need
to make this Paradigm leap over our
current crisis and demise so that that
does not become our future
and so this is the trick of many systems
thinkers around the planet and we're
working on this in our non-profit
Farmer's footprint uh the brilliant
Lauren Tucker has has tackled the
project to renour Studios and has
brought this to to bear with uh
Regenesis and and groups of systems
thinkers that for 30 years have been
realizing that the only way to really
create sea change in behavior is to
create a new field of awareness a new
Thought Field a new playground to play
in from a vision standpoint so instead
of trying to go and say well we got 10
million problems we got to go start
fixing each one of those we don't have
time for that we will go extinct trying
to do the whack-a-mole here's a problem
here's a problem here's a problem
approach we need to do the buck Mr
Fuller phenomenon which is we now need
to create the reality that makes the old
Humanity obsolete right and the new
reality which requires a reimagination
of systems top to bottom does demand an
elevation of Consciousness or a shift in
Awareness to uh you know sort of
conceptualize paradigms that don't
currently exist which is a big ask right
you're optimistic about this I look
around and I see you know all of the
dire consequences that uh you know I
shared at the outset which you just
mentioned but we all just we also just
experienced like I don't know a month
straight of rain in Los Angeles and it's
never been more green I've lived here
since 1996 and
now it's suddenly like some combination
of Ireland and Kauai that I haven't
experienced in the entire time that I've
lived here
the planet's ability to you know sort of
Marshal its own immune response
um is is nothing short of a Marvel right
and in thinking about kind of like you
know pull the final thread on this idea
of the macro and the micro when we look
at the ills of the planet from a macro
perspective we see inflammation right we
see inflammation in our politics and our
public discourse and we see inflammation
of you know in a more micro sense of of
of human biology right and what happened
what is inflammation it is our you know
it is our it is our bodies response to
disease or injury it's like an emergency
response to like repair something that
is wrong but inflammation we're seeing
inflammation in our in our kind of you
know culture right in our in in
Humanities you know kind of social
interaction Dynamic right and so
what is the inflammatory like what is
the what is the kind of um emergency
response to that like is that happening
in a macro sense I think we're being
called upon to attend to that right like
and it is much like the Fibonacci
sequence right like what is happening
you know when we cut our hand and and it
turns red or whatever we're having an
inflammatory response the inflammation
in in discourse is is demanding that we
kind of look at how we're interacting in
a way to try to repair it so that we can
get back to a healthier more productive
way of communicating with each other
which is part of your messaging right so
all of these things back to this point
of interconnectedness like there is
nothing that is not interconnected
everything you know every microcosm is
part of the macrocosm and we can't solve
those small problems
um if we lose sight of you know the
larger context in which they exist
yeah it's really well said you know
there's been huge books written on the
problem of the victim perpetrator coin
two sides to the same coin and it gets
you stuck in a trap and so if you are
the victim in a moment scenario you are
likely to reverse that become the
perpetrator in the next moment and that
could be
you know Germans getting crushed at the
end of world war one and they you know
are victimized two-thirds of their land
is taken away from them and they react
and become the perpetrators and try to
take back way more than they ever had
well this is the history of of conflict
and geopolitics dating all the way back
to the Inception of humanity the
Inception and so we have been flipping
this victim perpetrator coin back and
forth at the macro level
and I would say at the micro level down
to the family level down to the
individual level we flip this coin back
and forth all the time
uh all the way down to that individual
level where I can flip the victim
perpetrator on on myself in a day oh my
gosh I'm beating myself up right now and
oh my gosh now now I'm you know the the
victim of that and now I'm the
perpetrator of that you know so or the
abused person becomes the abuser that's
it so there is a freedom from that that
is deeply understood and I would say
it's a bit of a maybe it's a Trilogy I
don't know but the the third option
instead of flipping back and forth on
that same coin is to move into creative
mode
creation is the alternative to
perpetrator and victim you know and
becoming the Creator rather than the
perpetrator
takes an effort to forgive the
victimhood that preceded that moment and
so we are going to have to come to a
universal Universal moment of
forgiveness in these next couple months
years ahead forgive the journey that
we've taken and stop with the typical
activist approaches
there's the bad guys cutting down the
rainforest there's the bad guys pumping
oil out there's the bad guys you know
doing chemical farming there's the bad
guys doing pharmaceutical medicine
whatever it is
that needs to end we can't that doesn't
work we have to realize that's us being
self-abusive as a species that's that's
not us moving to the next thing the next
expression of our possibility
so we're gonna have to forgive
universally and move to this creative
moment as a species where we do
co-ovision that radical future where we
simply behave differently
and we get to see it happening out of
this pandemic you know you mentioned you
know some evidence of ecological
recoveries in places not expected with a
green California I agree it's just
stunning driving up to your place right
here like the hills never been so
verdant in the same way my gosh I never
saw such extraordinary Community
activation coming out of the tail end of
two years of isolation and of you know
intervention so for every action there's
an equal and opposite reaction and so we
are now in our death cycle which means
there's never been so much opportunity
for rebirth
and so this is I think where we're at
right now as we've just spent the last
50 years debating science about our own
endpoint the demise of our species the
demise of ecology climate change global
warming we've used all kinds of terms
for that side infertility and we use all
kinds of you know chronic diseases
cancer we use all kinds of words on that
side
it's time for us to forgive the journey
and realize we have one moment to
rebirth and in that rebirth we can move
into this creation mode where we're no
longer
stuck in that victim perpetrator
mentality what is necessary in that leap
I think in in and alongside that concept
of forgiveness is this movement from the
belief of scarcity into the state of
abundance
in California the last seven years huge
drought the scarcity of water has been
so palpable right you're out of water
the things are going reservoirs are out
and everybody's behaving in the scarcity
model of water
not recognizing that there's a a
geologic system in place that if worked
with if created with we could simply
change the amount of water in the
atmosphere
rainforest moved an enormous amount of
water back in the atmosphere and change
water patterns globally and all this
Earth is awfullying very simple it's a
carbon cycle in a water cycle and if we
bring all of our systems in line with
healthy carbon and water cycles our
forestry our agroforestry our Agronomy
our health systems our you know Energy
Systems they should all be based on
carbon and water cycles
and they should be closed loops and so
if we were to do this move from scarcity
to a state of realization of abundance
as this Earth does more Abundant Life
every iteration after every Extinction
there is more life more diversity and
more intelligence every time
and it's stunningly beautiful in its
advances right we go from palms and
ferns before the last Extinction 55
million years ago to deciduous trees and
wildflowers everywhere
that necessitated
a Extinction to get that level of new
viruses into the atmosphere to code for
the new life viruses are not living
things viruses are the packets of
genomic information that are the
possibility of the future
and so as we start to put many many
species
in this short conversation probably five
or six species could go extinct
those species under extinction level
stress are putting out new genetic
information that we call viruses or
exosomes or all kinds of new words out
there now
and they are literally releasing the
next iterations of those species that
could come next as the dust settles and
this death turns into a rebirth which
again again happens on this planet the
rebirth is going to be beautiful
and we just have a few years to decide
whether this new humanity is going to be
part of that that new future are we
going to rebirth with the planet or are
we going to be that sixth Extinction
event are we getting cataclysmic event
that allows for all that beauty and
explosion of nature to happen over the
next million years
and that's our gift to the planet is
that we were the asteroid this time we
were the thing that that destroyed the
Earth so that it could be rebirthed in a
higher level of intelligence everything
else maybe that's not that bad of a
story in the end yeah you seem neutral
on whether Humanity will make it or not
we are on the bubble right now and so we
need to shift in this decade
from
arguing over abstract science of climate
change and you know human health chronic
diseases pandemics all that into a new
paradigm where we're no longer bickering
over the abstract sciences and we now
only do applied science
and this is what I do every day with a
lot of joy is I try to imagine what is
the applied science that would clean up
this Earth quick enough that we could
actually start to have children again we
would have to get Plastics out of our
water because right now I think it's a
credit card every week that we consume
in Plastics into our bloodstream or some
ridiculous amount
that's largely why we're going into this
infertility crisis is too much Plastics
disruption of the endocrine system
through toxins and Plastics and all this
and stuff
so what's the what's the applied science
of the the beauty we see under the
microscope and the science we see on the
microscope is the mitochondria dudes
these little bacteria that live inside
ourselves generate all of the energy for
the cell to become Everlasting to really
become
irrepressible because if there's
unfettered access to information and
energy the cell will always repair
faster than it can enter
and so to that seven years ago we
decided Well we just need to build a
bunch of 40-foot mitochondrias that
could chew up all the Plastics of the
planet because all it's laying plastic
is the same as glucose or fatty acids
that your mitochondria are using it's
just a long chain carbon that has stored
sun energy inside it sunlight inside of
it a double carbon bond is a battery for
sunlight
and so Plastics tires agricultural
wastes currently methane off gassing
destroying the planet blah blah blah
that should be our energy sector we can
close the carbon Loop in energy so we
spent seven years engineering that we
built the first full Sky scale
mitochondria out in Denver last year
turned it on in February and now we're
going global with that technology that
company is called resource dynamics that
we started in it's so exciting each each
mitochondrial unit digests 100 000
pounds of waste daily
into biofuel
and biochar or carbon black or these
other critical commodities for closing
these carbon loops and soil systems and
others other places and so
that's the result of an applied science
out of a mitochondria in a Petri dish
over seven years because we were just
asked the question is it possible and
if you put a lot of smart people around
the possibility again you create that
phase possibility you create that space
and that's just what I do like the CEO
and founder of that company but I didn't
build any of that it took so many
Engineers so much smarter than me to
actually make that thing real
[Music]
so if I have a business Acumen that I'm
I'm starting to really embrace it's I
can hold that field of possibility for a
good long time of impossibility that's
interesting so I'm not sure I quite
understand so so correct me if I'm wrong
what you're saying is you have helped uh
develop a technology wherein a
mitochondria Rich environment has been
cultivated to consume uh waste
particularly in the form of plastic and
convert that into fuel is that what
you're saying yeah except we just blew
up one mitochondria into a 40-foot
version of it so we would try to imagine
a mitochondria that was 40 foot big
instead of a few microns inside your
cells like that's a biological thing
what do you mean 45 a 40 foot like what
are you saying exactly so mitochondria
used eight steps to break long carbon
chains into short carbon chains to
release all the energy
and so we knew that eight step model
would work for any long chain carbon
whether it was Plastics tires Farm waste
Etc so we developed an eight-step
thermal process to break double carbon
bonds just as the mitochondria used now
they use enzymes to to break that in
part and we're using thermal decoupling
or temperature shift and so but in the
same way that they're breaking it we
just use that model of okay long chain
to short chain carbons how do they do it
they break the double carbon bonds eight
times over
and so we just use that same model so
you're trying to do biomimicry
ultimately in engineering
in in energy sectors and people are now
doing this in houses my good friend Jose
Bakker in in Australia uh just finished
an incredible two-year project right in
the middle of fed Square in Melbourne
and uh it's called the the greenhouse
and uh future Food Systems it was the
concept and he was a restaurateur and
and she's a florist before that and
everything he touched just becomes so
beautiful and regenerative just because
he's one of those guys that can hold the
impossible for long enough that it
materializes right right under his feet
and so he materialized this three-story
home like two-bedroom house that would
grow more food produce more water and
more energy than it used and he plopped
his thing off grid just right down in
the middle of fed square a couple years
ago and got this thing growing and
running and had two chefs living in the
house and they had hundreds of thousands
of Australians come through and students
and everything else to to witness this
thing it is truly spectacular yeah I've
heard I've heard about that through
Darren o'lane I think he visited yeah
those guys so that so that is an example
of biomimicry at scale because he did it
over and over again so use biomimicry
and waste management with stool to to
gas to cook over he used it at each step
of the process of the biology or
metabolism of a a human system he
mimicked in a house so what you're
really looking at is a living organism
with many different organs that are
specialized to different things so this
is the biomimicry we need to Design
Within if it's not water and carbon
cycle the at its foundation we're going
to screws there's gonna be unintended
consequences of that technology a good
example of that is lithium we're right
now we're have all these teams going
into Central America jungles to try to
discover the next lithium of mine
that's not a solution for the planet
right there actually is no lithium cycle
in biology that's measured in anything
but maybe tens of millions of years it's
not an energy cycle for the planet and
so we the further we we demonize carbon
as our
you know ideal energy source the further
we're going to get away from the truth
of where does infinite energy come from
it is the relationship between Sunshine
CO2 and plants when I think about all of
this I think about it in the context of
of an arms race with a ticking clock
right like you're sharing all of these
new exciting technologies that that hold
you know extraordinary promise we
actually know how to solve a lot of
these problems but we're operating
against uh you know time in the sense
that you know the degradation is
escalating and our you know inability to
be efficacious in terms of of
manifesting solutions is is inhibited by
a lack of political will uh by you know
you know gigantic uh conglomerate
corporate interests invested in the
status quo or in you know the opposite
you know what is the solution to all
these problems to Consumer demand for
everything from you know lithium to oil
and everything in between all of these
you know forces that create these
tectonic plates that are progressing us
towards the future uh the dystopian
future as opposed to you know the future
that you're imagining and short of some
kind of systemic Revolution or a
complete revamping of systems uh in
terms of how we make Global decisions
and how we think about these problems
and solve them from a collective
perspective uh that requires you know
Global coordination it seems very
difficult that or or hard to imagine
that we're going to get there in time
before you know that that ticking clock
uh you know reaches its its end point
and we've passed the point of no return
I have an enormous amount of confidence
about something called Quorum sensing
this is where if enough of a population
starts to connect it starts to do this
hyper intelligence thing it starts to do
something that none of the constituents
could have ever imagined this happens in
Petri dishes you get enough bacteria
interacting and especially if they got a
little fungi in the mix they start to do
Quorum sensing right away Force do this
Quorum sensing Force start to add and do
this hyper intelligence thing of
resource management resource repair
the wildfires that tore through your
Canyons right here just you know four
years five years back
that inspired this massive communication
Network back in the mycelium came back
in because there was enough carbon
substrate in that soil to to regenerate
in a level that it had been failing in
for many decades of drought and so the
vertices that we're now seeing years
after that recovery are from this Quorum
sensing phenomenon where things get
better than ever imagined before because
of the the initial collapse and then the
recovering connectivity
and so project biome is trying to be the
first ecological you know puzzle piece
that's not out there to go and plant a
bunch of trees or go fix the rivers
directly instead we can be the
connective tissue to get all of the
people that already are fixing rivers
and fixing soil systems globally to
connect
and if we get enough mines connected
that already know the solutions are here
then that new world just emerges we will
do Quorum sensing as a species if we
connect enough people this is why I'm
back on your podcast again you connect
people so effectively
this is the fabric of our future this
one conversation held between millions
of people
right now
is that possibility that we connect just
enough Minds to suddenly do the Quorum
sensing event and we suddenly know the
future that we all feel in our hearts as
possible and that known future becomes
the reality it's not something that we
probably need to go engineer
I believe all my companies are going to
be gone in 30 years because we'll either
be extinct or they'll all be obsolete
because this new future is going to
dream up things that are so in League
with the infinite nature of nature
that even as good as a 40-foot
mitochondria sounds
it's it's still a finite version of an
infinite reality of true mitochondria
which are ethereal and and constantly
rebirthing themselves
there's something coming and I can feel
it under my skin and maybe I have to go
die and see it on the other side of the
veil but I know it's coming is a beauty
that I cannot even imagine
and this is maybe where we get back to
that beginning statement of the five
senses that we were given creates the
perception that we're separate from
um
I think that's actually telling of our
purpose
we were uniquely equipped with a
neurologic system that would interpret
the input from these five senses
that we were separate and it gave us the
perception of separateness for a lot of
potential vulnerability of scarcity and
everything else that's unfolded
but if we look to the Redemptive quality
of being
having that gift of perception of
separateness it may be so that we can
see beauty
if if you're in the water as a fish
your perception of the water is not
actually there it's it's it is the
substrate in which you live
you can't see the water per se you might
see light and some other things but the
water itself is that thing you are not
separate from it
this is why fish can be in you know
billions of of fish in these massive you
know uh swarms that are moving through
the ocean these huge coordinated
Fibonacci sequences moving as one
organism is because the water is there
is really they are the organism with the
water they're one with the thing
all of this
being outside the substrate of life
being perceiving that we are separate
from the water the air the soil
gives us the ability to uniquely see its
beauty
and it is teases my mind as to not is
that not the gift that we bring back to
this world
is the capacity to see her beauty
there's something amazing in quantum
physics it's called the observer effect
and as soon as an electron is seen it
changes its direction of spin
what is the next future of this world
may only resolve because there's a
species that came along to actually see
nature in her full Beauty
because the moment we see everything
[Music]
especially probably in a vibration of
gratitude we change the nature of the
whole fabric of everything that was
around us it has to change its direction
instantly and completely
and so I am curious to see if we don't
repeat another like 7 000 year
desertification ingredient of South
Africa but we actually make a paradigm
leap because Nature has been witnessed
on a level that she has never been seen
before in
why did we discover and develop the
electron microscope why did we make the
Hubble telescope in this extraordinary
telescope images are now coming back
with our version 2.0 of Hubble
why did we do that
what is our fascination with it I can
spend an hour looking through Hubble
Telescope images just mind blown
and I just get
it's a spiritual experience it's better
than any Cathedral I've ever stepped
into is looking at the beauty
through human eyes
of the cosmos
and in the microscope looking at the
beauty of a single cell rebirthing
itself when connected back to the
microbiome
it's so exquisitely beautiful and being
seen for the first time by human eyes
and so was our technological Journey
ultimately
to supercharge our Five Senses Into
seeing the full beauty of this planet so
that everything would change the very
matrix by which we live breathe think
and imagine within is here to shift in
this moment of Crisis that you so well
outlayed at the beginning
it's a beautiful sentiment and I share
uh you know this idea that that we you
know we have the capacity uh to Marvel
on a level that no other biological
creature uh you know is capable of and
there's something you know extraordinary
about that I think the path forward
however uh requires a certain level of
not only you know really indulging and
recognizing our capacity to you know see
the beauty from the mic from the micro
to the macro but also
um to develop a level of humility about
the capacity of our five senses but
because I think what what humans also do
which is you know sort of orthogonal to
what you just shared is is to believe
that we are capable of understanding
everything through these through the
limitations of the these five senses
without uh you know an appreciation for
the limitations of those senses without
inadequate
um
respect for the fact that those senses
are limited and and and our brains are
perhaps not as evolved as they could be
to recognize what is perhaps right in
front of our eyes uh and and easily
understood by you know brains that might
be a little bit bigger than ours right
so we think that we understand
everything that we can deconstruct
everything that we can categorize
everything and make sense of our world
as as as creatures who are who who you
know find comfort in in in identifying
patterns right and so to step out of
that and to say we have these five
senses they allow us to appreciate the
beauty they allow us to understand
certain things about how things operate
but let's also understand that maybe
we're not capable of really seeing the
full picture here and we should have a
healthy dose of humility about that and
uh and and with that level of humility
um perhaps not be so Hasty in the
decisions we make that have such vast
ramifications on you know planetary
Health and Human Health
oh that was a good one I love that
feeling and I feel like the humility is
the flip side of the coin of gratitude
right and so it's like those two things
go so beautifully hand in hand uh having
the humility to understand that we are
going to receive this future rather than
achieve this future uh that we can maybe
believe is possible is an exciting one
but our purpose is to be in this finite
existence of a human body so that we can
appreciate the smell of chocolate the
touch of a baby's hand
the face of an elder as they're dying
it is the finite nature of human life
that makes it beautiful
if it was infinite it would be dismal
it's for the beauty of the finite that
gets me excited to wake up again
tomorrow and it gets me excited about my
aging process too is this isn't
something to be resisted and this is one
of my concerns about the biohacking
world is why we put such fear of Aging
into people
are we afraid of wisdom
all right do you look at your your
grandmother that died a few years back
as a horrible failure because of the way
she aged now you remember the way it
felt when she spoke her wisdom to you
and told you something of truth that was
fractal through all of Nature and it hit
you in a place that was not five senses
mediated
we are resisting our own wisdom in this
biohacking journey towards a desire for
infinite youth are we ready to be finite
are we ready to birth into something so
much more I hope the species goes on to
participate in this rebirth on this
planet to realize some sort of beauty
that we can't even imagine
but I know for myself I'm not going to
be here to see it instead I want to be
the oak tree growing in the forest right
now putting out the mycelial networks of
the forest imagines that next reality
and when my oak tree falls
I want it to be just as the oak is in my
Virginia landscape when an oak Falls in
my land there and it starts to dissolve
into the soil it is an extraordinary
explosion of life
if you genetically sequence that trunk
at the moment that it falls it's one
species very limited few genes that make
it Oak came from a single Acorn if you
genetically sequence that log one year
after laying on the the forest floor
it's a hundred thousand species
hmm that's who I'm going to become yeah
I'm going to become on a thousand
species in that root ball that I get
buried under or in that ocean that my
ashes get scattered in whatever it might
be who are you going to become as Beauty
in and of itself with the spirit of
humility as you said and a deep Spirit
of gratitude and this just quivering
feeling under our skin of possibility
yeah that's that's really you know
beautifully
beautifully explained
um you know just to kind of close the
the book on on this idea of humility and
the capacity of our senses and the role
of humans to you know live integrated in
the world I think that you know breath
and all these other modalities have
their place to grab a glimpse of
something that you know lives just
beyond the capacity of our senses to you
know kind of calibrate in our day-to-day
experience but it's not to live out
there it's to then integrate it into our
experience and translate that into some
kind of you know positive change whether
that's in your personal life or in your
advocacy or kind of the Legacy that you
leave behind as the oak tree that falls
you know in the forest and you know on
that note of Legacy like you know that's
a very beautiful thought about the oak
falling and and you know the species
proliferating and all of that I've often
thought like when I die AI would it be
great if if I was just buried into a
garden and all these amazing plants grew
out of me and then all the people that I
loved like had a had a you know a
banquet and just ate all the food that
that grew out of my body and you know
the kind of
um extrapolation of your life and how it
you know and how that energy can
continue through the people that you
care about it's beautiful you know which
is cool
um but on this idea of I'm glad that you
brought up longevity right like this is
very much in in uh the vox populi it's a
zeitgeisty kind of thing right now
everybody's talking about lifespan
extension Health span extension a lot of
energy excitement money and science you
know is going into this right now the
quest to live to 200 and Beyond and
ultimately reach uh longevity escape
velocity where you know in other words
like for each year that we're alive
we're able to extend life beyond that
year
which to me is fascinating I've had a
number of guests on this show to discuss
this topic
um
and I'm certainly
uh not against the idea of exploring the
capacity of human biology to
be extended
but I do of course take issue with this
idea of immortality which to my mind
seems to be born out of a great fear or
an inability to really make peace with
our with our own you know kind of
mortality and the limited time that
we're you know here on Earth right like
a lot of this is being spawned by very
rich people who have everything in the
world and the one thing that they can't
control is time right so how do they
deploy their resources to you know
arrest that one thing that seems just
out of grasp for them and so how are you
like you've already kind of stated your
thesis on this but you know this is
happening and certainly you know
diagnostic tools are coming out of this
that are that are good and and helpful
and all of that but
how do we have a healthy relationship
with
um our own mortality and and uh uh you
know at the uh of course we want to
extend our to we want to be as vital as
long as we can right like nobody wants
to live their later decades decrepit or
losing their minds or unable to be
productive so of course we want to
enhance or increase the robustness of
that but we also need a healthy uh kind
of
um relationship with our own demise
yeah first of all I've you know bitten
blessed and we talked about it our first
podcast around hospice and watching
people cross that Veil The reason we are
afraid of death is because we can't
believe things could be better
and the people that cross that Veil
realized instantly that
it is so much better on the other side
in so many ways and that there there was
no more sense of scarcity when they came
back on this side and so the abundance
was on the other side of the veil not on
this side of the veil and so that was
quite a training in my own release of
fear of my own death you know during
those years in hospice care
but
I want to maybe come back to that
thought of you know some of these
Technologies are good and doing things I
think we can't actually make any real
honest or accurate judgment on any of
our Technologies being good or bad
until maybe a few more Thousand Years
goes by and we have different
perspectives because there's so many
unintended consequences of human
engineering that is outside of biology
and and it's it's scary for me to think
that that we're making judgments and
that's a good technology or bad
technology is AI a bad technology I
don't know we'll find out human
Innovation is the story of unintended
Concepts it's the story of unintensive
consequences that are born out of a
fundamental disconnect from nature at
its beginning well and and also a a
hubris
no obviously the hubris is the result of
the ego that steps in to protect the
individual that thought a guy rejected
right and so our original wound was
Rejection it was we all have an
abandonment disorder at our root and
then we developed an egoic mind and you
know social behavior to
try to staunch the fear guilt and shame
cycles that happen and once you're in
that abandonment disorder that keeps us
addicted great work on addiction that
I'm fascinated by is
um TJ Woodward's work around conscious
recovery and he's really good at helping
people get down to this route of
Abandonment disorders the reason they
have addiction to anything I've never
heard of him that's fast oh you would
love to have him on he's fun yeah he's
got not only books he's got an
incredible curriculum that kind of comes
alongside AAA as like a much more robust
look it kind of what is the root cause
and then what is your relationship back
towards addictive substances and he
changes the Paradigm completely you know
to really look at substance abuse as a
genius you know tool for survival of a
species that's in this you know deep
abandonment disorder for an individual
that's in deep abandonment disorder from
their parents that rejected them the
father that views them whatever it is
and so it's a beautiful model of again
fractals of what we've done to Nature
down at the individual level but what
you see when you're working through TJ
Woodward's work is oh my God this is the
whole Human Condition we're all addicted
to something and right now a lot of us
are addicted to our biohacking data and
so we are so addictive because we have
this fundamental abandonment disorder
way Upstream
what I love about
this Simplicity is is then rethinking
the word technology
we think of Technologies as things that
we can that build that are not of nature
that's our current con concept of
technology which discards the
possibility that a human cell with
trillions of atoms that have
self-organized into this thing is not a
technology
that diminishes the possibility that my
14 quadrillion mitochondria are not
Technologies living inside of myself
I believe we are the greatest technology
expressed by Nature so far this human
body is the greatest technology that's
been made by Nature this far I have a
high degree of confidence of that
my trust in that supersedes anything
that I can make that looks outside of
nature
we've defined nature that way even if
you go to the Oxford English Dictionary
nature is defined as
everything on the planet minerals plants
animals everything except humans or
things humans have made
really not only wrote ourselves out of
nature encapsulate humans as part of
nature a perfect encapsulation of the
problem the dualistic nature of
Separation Humanity yeah like inner like
contemplates our role
so what if the greatest technology ever
made is is this human body
what is it capable of doing to CR to
shift from victim perpetrator into this
true creative state where it can create
universes
what is there an opportunity for me to
tap into something so much deeper than
my five senses or my two hands could
ever create because I am a generative
Center and if I can think it it's
occurring somewhere in the Multiverse if
I can imagine it it's occurring
somewhere out there and there's a lot of
people that believe that's true
from indigenous peoples all the way
through if you've dreamed it it's
happening somewhere right now in the
Multiverse
how would I possibly get there how would
I get to this place where I switched
from victim perpetrator on a daily basis
to true creator
and of all places that you know maybe
shoved a huge sign of post in my face
unless it was the course of Miracles
there's this extraordinary description
in there of how humans have become
addicted to human relationship in the
effort to complete ourselves we see
something different than ourselves we
feel incomplete and we figure oh that's
the other half if we put that together
then then I'll be whole and we become
codependent in those relationships so
that's defined in that space as special
relationship
the beauty that is the opposite of that
that is this promise that kind of sits
there is that at some point in the near
future
[Music]
two human beings could come together
that have completed themselves no longer
looking outside of themselves to realize
that they are a complete technology they
are a complete being they have all that
was ever intended at the highest
technological level of Nature's whole
expression right within themselves and
it says that when those two people saw
each other for the first time they would
truly be seen because in the split state
of the egoic mind that's protecting
ourselves from this addictive
abandonment disorder we can only see a
mirror of ourselves
so as much as I love you as much as I
can talk to you about all of your
incredible attributes every time I look
at you I'm only either seeing the best
of me or the worst of me
and that is the result of this Schism
the split psychology of the egoic mind
which is too afraid to see you
ultimately for the the incredible nature
that you really are and so we protect
ourselves Behind these egoic shields so
that we cannot be seen and we cannot see
when we stop with the addiction to the
outside world through our relationships
through our things and we become whole
for a split second if two would see each
other
the amount of love and awe and just
magnanimous sense of just amazement and
wonderment that would come out of that
moment would send Ripple effects to the
whole energies of the planet and through
the species and we will make our
Paradigm leap and so it just takes two
people to finally see each other to be
that next technology of humanity is what
we're told in that incredible course so
is that possible that we will let go
down that egoic Shield long enough and
heal our deep abandonment disorder to
become whole enough for a moment that
this observer effect that we talked
about earlier that if we really see the
universe for all its beauty it will
switch completely every atom will change
we only have to do that to one other
human only see one other human
completely and that observer effect will
change everything I believe
um
yeah that's uh that's a that's a
beautiful and complex set of sentiment I
you know in contemplating that I think
of the human condition as as one of
suffering born out of our inability to
you know see ourselves as we truly are
and instead live in comparison to others
and uh and in
um
and in relationship to you know a past
and a future from which we construct
narratives that lead to our own
suffering and separation right and so
basically what you're saying is
the the path forward is
presence and the capacity to you know
let go of those narratives and to allow
ourselves to step into
um a greater sense of self-awareness
that is
much more capacious and and uh
and contemplative of of how we live sort
of out of time right like if we can just
step out of that past narrative and our
Neurosis about the future and our need
to be calibrated in the context of of uh
you know how we relate to externalities
that we would be able to touch deeper
meaning within ourselves and and connect
with
um
that kind of you know Infinite Source of
of love that that truly allows us to
then in turn connect with another human
being and set off that like
chain reaction that you're speaking of
is that a fair it's exact reflection of
what you're getting at it's perfectly
said
in our in our eight week Journey we put
everybody one-on-one with a coach
historically and then the pandemic
happened and we saw people just being so
isolated and lonely we and being
economically challenged we put people to
make it cheaper and maybe give them a
sense of community into groups of six or
eight people with a coach still but six
or eight people healing instead of one
person trying to heal the results have
been unbelievable
the speed at which we can heal in
community when we witness one another's
healing Journeys when we learn and are
inspired by the others healing journey
is so much more logarithmically fast
than I ever anticipated I resisted group
coaching all the way up until the
pandemic because I thought it was so
important because I was in my old
patriarchal thing about as the
practitioner and the patient and that's
that's the thing that really no it's
being seen and no wonder that six people
in a room are going to see that
individually differently through a
different lens through a different
perspective see Beauty in a different
way and that person relate to that
beauty in a different way and so the
speed is there and so I'm convinced that
we heal faster in a connected Community
where a safe space is created
and healing doesn't happen through the
breath work through the food
interventions or all the other eight
things that we need healing happens when
you're reconnected to your original Mass
relationship to yourself and others to
yourself first but you can't find self
until you're in relationship to others
but as soon as you do find self the
speed at which
those cells repair it's just never been
witnessed it's it's just so
instantaneous we actually have a word in
medicine that we had to create for this
because it was super awkward to write in
the in the medical
chart miracle happened you know and so
we had to come up with something that we
could put into a CPT Medicare code that
said something about the fact that
disease just spontaneously disappeared
and so we could call it spontaneous
remission
when disease that's been there for
decades and is threatening life itself
suddenly disappears literally in a day
and it's witnessed so frequently in
medicine I've seen it in the cancer
realm you know so often where you have
stage four cancer and tumors everywhere
and Mets to the brain you got three
weeks to live
and then suddenly the person's condition
just starts to slowly improve and
you you do scans and there's nothing
there
meaning there's not even a scar where
the tumors were it literally looks as if
the tissue returned to some original
design
that's spontaneous remission and there's
a medical term for it because it happens
I believe it happens when you are
witnessed by yourself ultimately if you
can really see the beauty within you
which is to take that humble pill maybe
but also to take a huge
reintroduction to your own sovereignty
your own sacred nature your your mega
megalithic beauty within you if you can
see that for a second there the speed at
which you return to your original design
is staggering and we have to create
something other than the world miracle
for it because it's awkward but it
happens and if that's possible then
can't we do that for a species can't we
go through a radical remission can we go
through a spontaneous remission
as a species and resolve that original
wound of the abandonment disorder of our
nature and start to live within her
instead of against her you mentioned the
word sovereignty and and that's really
kind of a touchdown or or a theme that
percolates across you know so many of
the the the subjects and topics that
that you talk about
um this this idea that we must shoulder
responsibility for our own path that we
you know need to kind of you know
respect our intuition cultivate that
rather than you know basically
um
you know divest ourselves of that
responsibility onto other people who
tell us what to do or
um
or uh you know kind of uh you know shirk
climbing that mountain for ourselves
because it's just easier just have
somebody else say you should do this or
you should do that and I think that this
idea of sovereignty is is something
that's like rising in the Consciousness
like people understanding like oh I do
need to take responsibility for myself
like I do you know want to step into uh
self-efficacy and um
a sense of of ownership of my own path
and that includes of course like what
are the foods that I'm eating like how
am I you know cultivating sovereignty in
these other areas of my life which gets
into uh regeneration like we can't sit
here for a couple hours and not talk
about the work that you're doing in
regenerative soil and and you know
what's happening with with Farmer's
footprint so you know give us a sense of
kind of where things are at with that I
think you know basically like when we
first spoke this was an idea then it was
sort of a Content play you were making
documentaries and
um you know video projects telling the
stories of of these farmers and what's
going on with the soil but the current
state of your non-profit efforts in this
in this world have really matured like
you're doing a lot more than last time
we spoke
yeah it's been really exciting to see
that kind of evolution revolution could
continue to catch its own momentum and
this is again where you kind of hold the
field as a group of people and then see
something you could have never imagined
come out of that field you know and so
there's so many brilliant people now
working within that Farmer's footprint
context which was our first project
within project bio which was the one I
was talking about earlier but one of our
favorite quotes that's been held so so
brilliantly by our executive director
David Leon and the teams that he's
helped to assemble over these years is
that humans are not made of cells but we
are made of stories
and that really does play true for
through everything we've been talking
about today if we can Envision that next
story ourselves will
self-organize to achieve that future and
so we've been storytelling throughout
this and you and I share enormous
respect for a sovereign being named Liam
rasovich who's here with us who she's
somewhere in the dark out in there there
and the wings there but she began with
you and and Julie telling stories around
food and she's now telling these stories
on a grand scale and this is is now I
think her journey really emblematic of
our entire Journey as a regenerative
family which is that
what it works at the small level as has
to be occurring at the same time and at
the big level and so starting to tell
really the face of global regeneration
at the nation state level or the the
bioregional level is our next journey
into the applied science of regeneration
we've done the individual stories of
farmers and we will not stop that
because it I would believe each farmer
that is seen increases the Quorum
sensing for this future as well you see
a farmer they become a new generative
Center for their entire Community most
farmers are being unseen and are at the
highest risk of suicidality for that
invisibility within the Matrix of our
current socio economic systems and so
reconnecting Farmers is critical to our
future but lay and the rest of us are
seeing that there's now this opportunity
to start telling a much larger story of
regeneration and its potential to heal
our macro relationship to the planet not
just to the carrot on the plate but to
them the complete ecosystem we can have
healing there and really a journey back
into our nature at that grand level
and one piece of the puzzle that's
really just dropped for me in these
recent months we've had the blessing of
working with a lot of the uh the pupils
out of South Africa that really built
the successful anti-apartheid movement
and took down that that age-old you know
oppression of the British government and
previous to that the Dutch government
the French government Etc and they came
out of that as a nation just so recently
and those great leaders of the
anti-apartheid movement that came out of
Mandela's efforts and the like they
operationalized that through Community
activation and it's taught me something
fundamental that I think I was lacking
from my understanding of regeneration in
that I if you go to the project biome
website that we made five years back or
something that it it says we're gonna we
need solutions for soil water and air
if we can get those three systems
working then we're gonna have a
generative plan and all this
five years later I'm quite convinced
that neither soil nor water nor air need
to be fixed they are generative
ecosystems in and of themselves and they
will heal in within a matter of years of
the departure of humanity they don't
need saving
they they that's abstract to their very
existence which is permanent because
there's always a soil carbon motorcycle
on this Earth it's infinite
so this is where I'm starting to realize
that project biome and our focus on
stories has to do with the fourth
ecosystem if you will or the fourth
element of nature which is humanity
soil water and air those regenerative
centers the only piece we really need to
solve for is human expression of our
nature
and so for project biome to really step
into its fullness we're going to begin
not mapping ecosystems and everything
else that we anticipated I believe we're
going to be able to step back and learn
a lesson from the anti-apartheid
movement and so many other social
movements that have been successful in
India and other elsewhere
at Gandhi and the like and and his
messaging
the message is that the human needs to
find itself again and as soon as you do
no matter how humble your life may
appear you become this creative Center
that can change the face of everything
and so really we are going to relearn
Humanity in the context of soil water
and air rather than try to go fix soil
water in air when we see our true
identity Within These infinite Loops of
energy and creativity that this planet
has given us an opportunity to mix with
we will much quicker realize that future
that we all want and so
the maturation of my journey is
realizing we are here to be part of a
human healing that will put ourselves
back in harmony with soil water and air
globally and we will see a generative
Planet once again that has healed itself
many times over with or without humans
present and we will all heal together
towards this future
and to get there we'll have to take the
little fundamental steps that you've
laid out during this yeah and what is
the what are the brass tacks of that
like what is the what are the logistical
steps of that human evolutionary process
I think it's one it can have many
Logistics within it but it's
connectivity
and we see this in the petri dish review
connect cells they go into a generative
thing that you can't imagine having
happen we literally need connectivity
right now
and we need it around one piece of us
which is the creative potential within
us and so we're trying trying to start
to reimagine the internet as a mycelial
network and what that would look like
and really what it comes down to is can
we connect humans over a light curiosity
and if we do that I think we see the
whole thing shift so what is the
mechanics of everything connectivity
what is the purpose of connectivity to
create more biodiversity
and so you will know that you're part of
the connected and beautiful future if
there's more biodiversity in your life
every day are there more choices on the
dinner table for your children more
colors on the plate more sources for
those Foods is that food being sourced
from the soils of your backyards that
are now growing foods that replace the
monoculture lawn that was there last
year are you going to regrow the gardens
that fed this country and most of the
world today
by reconnecting you will find more
biodiversity and so that's your
breadcrumbs on your road to being part
of this Futures how many people are you
connected to how many parts of nature
are you connected to how many trees have
you said Thank you to today
how many sunrises did you wake up to see
last week how connected are you there
and is if the evidence is there's more
biodiversity in your life then it's not
an abstract observance of that Sunrise
that was a sunrise that got integrated
and you took it back into the five
senses world and says I'm going to call
that neighbor who looks so lonely I'm
going to reach out to the nursing home
down the roadway and see if they need a
volunteer just come and sit with some
Elders before they die
I'm going to get connected and if if the
connection results in more biodiversity
of thought experience human touch hugs
human breath nature then you're on on
the path and we're all going to meet on
the other side of that that rebirth Veil
and we're going to come out of that womb
in an ecstatic state of existence
ecstatic state of existence
spoken like a good Guru and cult leader
the best of it I mean it is beautiful
though you know and thinking about that
it is it is basically trying to uh uh
um Step Into You know the nature of our
forest root systems which are you know
our our are naturally driven to expand
and connect or our mycelium networks
that are creating these vast and
intricate uh webs of communication that
you know basically provide the
foundation for their
survival and allow them to thrive and
this is you know the blueprint for
Humanity as well and yet we find
ourselves in an increasingly fractured
and isolated state that is divorcing us
from that blueprint and that Birthright
and the call to action as I hear you
saying is to recapture that and to
understand that much like the mycelium
or the root systems we must do the same
right and so maybe a good way to kind of
end this is with some calls to action uh
you know about how to do that like how
to you know how to you know cultivate
that level of connectivity in our life
that can lead us into you know a greater
sense of self-efficacy sovereignty
um ikigai purpose all of that like that
raises the floor of our Collective
Consciousness so that we can solve these
problems uh you know but practical
things right for the everyday person who
you know a lot of the ideas that we've
been talking about today are are pretty
you know ephemeral right sort of like
listen I'm working two jobs I got kids
like I love Zach I love what he's saying
I feel inspired by his words
um but tell me what I can do right now
here today to help myself help the
um you know well-being of my family and
and and and and hopefully you know allow
me to be a more
productive member of my community in
service to the ideals that you know Zach
is espousing
I mean you start by categories of
experience in your week we could start
with a big one of food it's something we
do multiple times every day all of us
and so starting at your food and looking
at where where monoculture and monotony
has snuck into your behavior it's
Universal we are all eating about five
different meals and we cycle them and so
starting there and starting to ask
yourself how you can diversify that I'm
a strong believer in the power of
getting your hands in the dirt and that
can start very simply if you are doing
the two jobs and everything is done
working get the kids involved too and
just plant a mint plant in a couple pots
on the front stoop or on the patio or in
the apartment Window and having the kids
involved in that process will change
their philosophy and their psychology
very quickly as well so grow something
in a pot if that's all the more you can
handle but we've just launched the
Garden Club so you can go to Farmers
footprint.us and enjoy that you know
experience of the 101 on gardening
really because we've forgotten it we're
two generations out in the US from
knowing how to grow 40 of our food in
our backyard garden so the Garden Club
really takes you back into that simple
step-by-step process that can take you
from no idea how to even open up a seed
packet or maybe not even know where to
buy a seed packet to having a really
burden and and diverse uh food system in
your own backyard that replaces you know
the Kentucky Bluegrass or whatever is
there that's the biggest you know third
largest monoculture in the United States
is backyard Lawns 40 million Acres of
lawn that's 40 million Acres waiting to
be turned into a food system that would
be so resilient that there would be no
hunger left within this country let
alone the others that would follow suit
so the food is ready to be grown the
land is there to be grown and cultivated
and the soils will improve as soon as we
return biodiversity to them so learn how
to garden Garden Club Farmers for
print.us get engaged with Farmers around
the the area so the simplest going to a
farmer's market simple as checking out
and see if there's any csas that are
delivering food boxes to your
neighborhood these are ways to start to
understand the food system at the larger
level
getting out of the box of food the the
packaged food that's coming in the box
if you have to open two or three levels
of packaging before you got your food
you're really not helping the future at
this moment we got to get you back
touching real food again sauteing
carrots and onions is an insanely
fragrant and just gustatory experience
like it doesn't get much better than
carrots celery and onions
gustatory it's the sense of taste okay
that's good I always use like learn like
three or four from you every podcast so
um so there's this this opportunity to
engage the senses again in our food as
we start to heal the land with our
re-engagement of that so get engaged
there and then the excitement of
bringing in your government to help out
with us at the macro scale is really
happening you just had Cory Booker on he
and I have done a lot of work around the
glyphosate message we have a glyphosate
campaign running on right with Farmer's
footprint right now and the glyphosate
campaign is bringing a an understanding
that we're not just using this the weed
killer we're using it as a crop
treatment on the food right before we
harvested and so we're using it as a
desiccant drying agent across many
different crops wheat was the first one
in the 1990s and then the debut of
gluten sensitivity out of that and then
we did soybeans and now we some of my
colleagues running around saying that
we're we're allergic to the compounds
the lectins that are in legumes you know
yeah maybe so now that we're in
glyphosate heaven but before glyphosate
we were eating these things
at any rate so the the answer is really
activism at that level is starting to be
heard and so Cory Booker and many of the
other sitting on the AG committee I've
had the opportunity to sit with and and
there really is an appetite for change
at the farm bill and other places to
start to clean up our food system in a
way that it really wasn't there wasn't a
lack of awareness Science Education all
that historically and I I've been you
know testifying with groups of people to
the EPA for years as to the dangers of
glyphosate in our food it's pro-cancer
stuff all this stuff with no no effect
and it's been really wonderful to
realize it's because I was going through
a regulatory process that it wasn't
working as soon as you go through a
relationship process everything starts
to move and so this is a good lesson to
us as Citizens the Civic process is not
one of of railing against your your
politicians or appealing to your
regulatory committees it's about
building relationship non-judgmental
relationship has to be ahead and so go
and meet your legislators and start a
relationship there and the regulatory
Community will be able to change the
regulatory can't be the Agent of Change
to Washington DC it just doesn't work
that way you're pushing on the Rock at
the end of the the Avalanche at that
point you got to go uphill and figure
out why the Avalanche happened and I'm
so delighted in talking to all these
lawmakers on Capitol Hill that they just
didn't know that information that we
were presenting to the EPA it wasn't
trickling there and so they're like
that's as easy we control the farm bill
we're the ones that actually allocate
all the funds from the farm bill and
we've spent you know a trillion dollars
on the farm bill in the last 10 here so
there's a lot of capital ready to Pivot
here at the governmental levels just as
there is at the industry level and just
as there is in healthcare and Beyond so
instead of regulatory Solutions we need
relationship Solutions and we need to
rebirth our Civics again and so to this
end a group of us have created The
Institute of natural law so get engaged
that way uh we'll have our public facing
uh non-profit up and going with the
websites and engagement platforms all
that in the coming months but the
Institute of natural law is
re-understanding civics in the context
of these laws of nature we've covered
today because there is to imagine that
politics is a result of of
of polarized opinions that just fight
until one wins or the other that's not
nature the nation never done anything
that way and so our very socio-political
methods are at a wonderful Tipping Point
where we can rebirth the Republic that
was really seen in this country a couple
hundred years ago as a possibility and
of course that was built on the the
understanding Confucius brought to China
and the understanding the Iroquois
brought to 600 nations in in North
America before colonialism
natural law has been running long and
hard and creating Beauty and Harmony and
long-standing you know creative
governments and creative Nations next to
one another for the really since the
beginning of civilization as we
understand and we can return to that
quite simply by applying natural law
back into the system and so returning to
our original documents and finding that
so uh Farmers footprint.us Institute of
natural law adoption journey of
intrinsic health.com if you feel like
you need a team of people around you if
you want to committee around you to heal
within you can go to that website and
engage you can certainly take the eight
week course but we also have a
membership program that's very cheap per
month to just engage with that Global
community and so even if you're not
going to take the coursework you can be
part of the think tanks and everything
else that are coming out of it because
as soon as somebody shifts out of that
victim perpetrator mentality becomes the
Creator they are a creative epigenetic
genetic change agent within the
community and this is what's happening
now so journey of intrinsic health is
now an app it's a community app it's
keeping people connected after the
course and as a self-generating space
for people to create their own Avenues
of change and transformation and so get
engaged journeymantrinsichealth.com
Farmers footprint.us for Education just
zackbushmd.com all my stuff is there for
free and just dig deep there if you want
the soil science around everything we're
talking about in the Petri dishes and
all that that's intelligenceofnature.com
and an opportunity to really dig in
there so lots lots to go to yeah that's
a lot I mean beautifully put I love this
idea of you know back to this idea of
sovereignty and the notion of you know
cultivating your inner Creator and and
really you know shouldering the the the
realization and the responsibility that
you can make a change in in my
conversation with with Senator Booker it
was all about that it's like
everybody has a platform everybody has
relationships how are you using your
voice holding on to you know hope even
in the face of you know extensive you
know perhaps you know impossible
obstacles but understanding that this is
what we're here to do right and and you
know the fact that you have developed a
relationship with him I think is
beautiful because it is about it is
about you know relationships that's how
we move forward that's how progress is
made and
um and we all have a voice you know and
I think it is incumbent upon us to to
you know kind of use that voice and to
you know develop uh you know on your on
your idea of diversity to develop more
diversity in our lives on our plate but
also in our communities like diversity
like your point that you know nature is
nature is always moving towards greater
and greater diversity right that's
someone that's a law that's a lot so
it's like how can we do that in our own
lives how can we cult cultivate more
diversity in our relationships in our
experiences how can we step outside of
our comfort zone to you know experience
greater diversity in our life on our
plate in our in our relationships Etc
like that seems to be a path towards
greater greater Health as a kind of
Golden Rule right
um
along those lines actually I think you
just brought it into my brain with a
final little story that encapsulates
this whole thing
including the longevity piece we've been
talking about which is uh I was speaking
at this event Northern Virginia probably
six or seven years back and
um they flew over this couple from
icaria Greece in their 60s that live on
a 500 year uh Family Farm Family
Vineyard they grow grapes and olives
they flew them over to prepare a
five-course Greek meal for the speakers
of this little event
it was pretty epic experience this five
course meal they had forged in backyard
gardens around Northern Virginia for for
three or four days to get the
ingredients for this meal for 17 people
and every course they served was such a
ritual of the description of of the food
itself where the ingredients related to
its ecosystem and the love that they put
into each thing and stories of family
with each ingredient and their memories
of the onions their grandmothers and so
such a journey into this meal and at the
end of it I stood up and and like did
this epic Zach Bush toast that I thought
was just so brilliant you know it
probably went on for 10 minutes long in
the microbiome and it was like in the
beauty of the cosmos and I guess so so
pleased with this thing and uh and
everybody's crying and like I was just
like home run you were like yeah in your
flow and this guy from a career gets up
thick Greek accent doctor that was all
very very interesting but you're
completely wrong
it was one of these magical moments
where you go from Flow State to like hit
the brick wall because this guy just
spoke his truth and said you are
completely wrong and I had just espoused
everything I'd learned through 45 years
of my life at that point and he just
said I was completely wrong not slightly
wrong completely wrong and he said the
reason that we live long in icaria
Greece is because not the food or the
soil we grow it in as you think or I
don't know what the microbiome really
refers to but it's none of that it's
because every table in icaria there's an
empty chair sat in hopes that somebody
knew that we don't know will come sit
and eat with us
that's why we live long and Hickory
agrees and so that's the biodiversity
that we could learn
in a in a country where we now eat 32
percent of our meals alone behind a
steering wheel
it is time to re-engage folks and food
is here as a focus of Fellowship not
isn't just nutrients and so if you're
going to lay a plate of food on your
table set an extra chair and create a
social environment where it's likely
somebody will show up and and fill that
chair and so we have the opportunity to
do it at this Grass Roots level as
simple as the meal and the person
showing up and without the aura ring
without the data we will live longer for
the wisdom and beauty that we will gain
from that meal seeing that new person
and being seen by that new person such
that we would change every atom in our
bodies to become something different to
that tomorrow
I think you uh planted the flag for
today with that thought
um thank you it's uh
really beautiful it's always a gift to
share space with you and spend time with
you and uh
and uh and uh you know really just you
know absorb your energy and and and
share your wisdom and experience and you
know I love you I'm your biggest fan I'm
here to support you so
there's always a chair open for you my
friend to be continued because I I got
an outline here full of all kinds of
stuff we didn't even get to today but I
think we'll be good enough for today
um as I mentioned at the outset I
believe this is your fifth appearance on
the podcast we have hours and hours of
of discourse between us so if you're
interested in anything from you know
glyphosate to many of the other subjects
that uh that we discussed today there's
plenty to mine so we'll link up in the
show notes uh URLs to all of those past
episodes with episode numbers and you
know again so if this is your first
exposure to Zach on this show you're new
to the show uh Lots there for for for
you to kind of dig into and explore and
educate yourself thank you we'll be back
in the ring again cheers thank you very
much peace plants